in cloud computing the competition for
leadership is a quite tough three-way
race
amazon web services
microsoft azure and google cloud
platform clearly are the top cloud
companies who are commanding lead in the
infrastructure as a service and platform
as service markets
hey everyone i'm shamlee and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on aws versus azure versus gcp
in this video we will compare and
contrast aws azure and gcp based on a
few related concepts around these cloud
computing platforms
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top cloud platforms
and will also let us figure out the
individuality of each one of them
but before starting with the comparison
let's have a quick introduction of aws
versus azure versus gcp
so let's get started
amazon web services or aws is a cloud
computing platform that manages and
maintains hardware and infrastructure
reducing the expense and complexity of
purchasing and running resources on site
for businesses and individuals
these resources are available for free
or for a fee per usage
microsoft azure is a cloud computing
service that it offers a collection of
cloud computing services for building
testing deploying and managing
application in the cloud including
remotely hosted and managed versions of
microsoft technology google cloud
platform offers a variety of cloud
computing services for building
deploying scaling monitoring and
operating a cloud
the services are identical to those that
power google products such as google
search gmail youtube
and google drive
now let's move on to the comparison
between aws assure and gcp
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like
origin
service integration
availability zone
cloud tools like compute
storage
networking
market share
pricing
and at last who uses them
now
let's move ahead and start with the
first comparison origin
in the year 2006 amazon web services aws
was introduced to the market
and in the year 2010
azure launched its services
whereas on the other hand gcp was
established in the year 2008.
from the start aws has been supportive
of the open source concept but the open
source community has a tense
relationship with azure
on the other hand gcp similar to aws
provides google cloud with manage open
source services that are tightly linked
aws offers services on a large and
complex scale that can be manipulated
but azure support is comparatively low
quality
whereas gcp's monthly support price is
almost 150 dollars for the silver class
which is the most basic of services and
is quite expensive
now let's move on to the service
integration of these cloud platforms
service integration is a set of tools
and technology that connects different
applications systems
repositories and data and process
interchange in real time
aws makes it simple for users to combine
services such as amazon ec2 amazon s3
beanstalk and others
on the other hand azure allows customers
to effortlessly combine azure vms
as your app service sql databases and
other services
whereas users can utilize gcp to combine
services such as compute engine
cloud storage and cloud sql
now that we know briefly about all these
cloud platforms let's have a look at the
availability zones of these platforms
because aws was the first in the cloud
domain they have had more time to build
and extend their network
but
azure and gcp both have various
locations around the world
but the distinction is in the amount of
availability zones they have
aws now offers 66 availability zones
with an additional 12 on the pipeline
close to it azure is available in 140
countries and is available in 54 regions
throughout the world
but google cloud platform is now
available in 20 global areas with three
more on the way
now let's move on to the next important
factor which is tools
now let's move ahead and have have a
look at the first feature
which is compute
elastic compute cloud or ec2 is aws
compute service which offers a wide
range of features including a large
number of instances
support for both windows and linux high
performance computing and more
as sure on the other hand virtual
machines is microsoft azure's core
cloud-based compute solution it includes
linux windows server and other operating
systems as well as better security and
microsoft program integration
in comparison to its competitors
google's computing services catalog is
somewhat smaller
compute engine that companies principal
service offers custom and pre-defined
machine types
per second invoicing linux and windows
support and carbon neutral
infrastructure that uses half the energy
of traditional data centers
within the compute category amazon's
different containers services are
gaining prominence it has docker
kubernetes and it's also far gate
service
which automates server and cluster
management when using containers as well
as other alternatives
azure unlike aws uses virtual machine
scale sets of two container services
azure container service is based on
kubernetes and container service
uses docker hub and azure container
registry for management
for enterprises interested in deploying
containers google offers the kubernetes
engine
it's also worth noting that google was
significantly involved in the kubernetes
project
providing it extensive knowledge in this
field
now let's move on to the next parameter
of comparison which is storage
simple storage service
for object storage elastic block storage
for persistent block storage and elastic
file system for file storage among aws
storage offerings
block storage for rest based object
storage of unstructured data queue
storage for a large volume workloads
file storage and disk storage are among
microsoft azure core storage services
gcp offers an increasing number of
storage options its unified object
storage service
cloud storage also has a persistent disk
option
relational database service or rds
dynamodb nosql database elastic
in memory data store
redshift data warehouse neptune graph
database and database migration service
are all sql compatible databases offered
by amazon
the database choices in azure are
specially wide
sql database mysql
database and postgre sql database are
the three sql based choices
when it comes to databases gcp
offers the sql based cloud sql and cloud
spanner a relational database built for
mission critical workloads
now the next parameter is networking
aws uses amazon virtual private cloud
or vpc
on the other hand azure uses
azure virtual network
we net
and gcp uses cloud virtual network
now let's move on to the another factor
which is market share
and pricing
all these cloud services are based on
comparative pricing strategy which means
you need to pay on the basis of its
usage
according to canalis the worldwide cloud
market rose 35
to 41.8 billion in the first quarter of
2021.
aws accounts for 32 of the market
with azure accounting for 19
and google accounting for seven percent
on one hand amazon charges on a yearly
basis and on the other hand microsoft
azure and google services charge on a
minute basis and also of them provide
you a standard price for you to access
these services
aws charges roughly 69 per month for a
very basic instance with two virtual
cpus and 8gb of ram
and aws largest instance with 3.84 db of
ram and 128 vcpus
will set you back roughly 3.97 per hour
but in azure the same type of instance
one with two v cpus and 8 gb of ram cost
roughly 70 dollar u.s
per month and asia's largest instance
has 3.89 tb of ram
and 128 virtual cpus
it costs about 6.79 per hour
compared to aws gcp will supply you with
the most basic instance which includes
two virtual cpus and eight gigabytes of
ram for 25 percent less as a result it
will set you back roughly to 52 dollar
every month and the largest instance
that include
is 3.75 db of ram and 160v cpus it will
cost you around 5.32 dollar per hour
amazon other than this also provides
spot instances reserved instances and
dedicated host where you can look for
multiple offers and discounts
but for ensure it provides special
prices to developers based on situations
or even ensure hybrid benefit which
benefits your organization up to 40
percent if it uses microsoft software
in their data centers
whereas google offers quite a sorted
pricing to its customer compared to
other two
it gives you sustained use discounts
which activate if you use the same
instance for a month
the printable instance which is very
similar to amazon spot instances
but one thing is common in all three
cloud services which is they all offer
long term discount
now let's have a look at the last
comparison which is companies using them
because aws is the oldest player in the
cloud business
it has the largest user base and
community support as a result aws has
the largest number of high-profile and
well-known clients including netflix
airbnb unilever bmw samsung mi senga and
others
with time azure is getting a large
number of high-profile customers
azure currently boasts around 80 percent
of fortune
500 firms as customers johnson controls
polycom fujifilm hp honeywell apple and
others are among its key clients
google cloud on the other hand uses the
same infrastructure as google search and
youtube and as a result many high in
enterprises
trust google cloud hsbc paper
20th century fox bloomberg domino's and
other among google clouds many clients
so this was all about aws versus assure
versus gcp
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important do
let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on aws
versus azure versus gcp and learn
something new from it if you like this
video then please hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here